(cheerful music)
- You know, there's summer
and spring and winter,
but fall is definitely the best season,
and I'm gonna tell you why.
Fall means sweater weather.
Everyone looks good in sweaters.
Look at this tiny human girl.
That should be you.
Let's get real.
Pumpkin spice is awesome
and goes with everything.
Grab yourself a steamy
cup of pumpkin spice latte
and treat yourself.
Fall also means county
fairs are popping up
left and right.
They are fun.
They are cheap.
Go grab yourself some funnel cake.
Go ride that Ferris Wheel.
Look at how pretty it is.
Don't tell me you forgot
about Thanksgiving.
That is the best.
You get to eat so much food
with so many people that you like.
Look. (murmuring)
Look at this lady.
She has never been happier
in her entire life,
and that's because the trees
go from normal looking things
into majestic creatures.
I said that, yes.
Hey, if you're allergic to the outdoors
and can't do all of that, guess what?
Fall means great stuff indoors too.
Fall TV,
oh my gosh, girl,
what are we watching tonight?
Is it Shonda?
There you have it,
so many reasons why fall
is the best season ever.
Don't mind me.
I'm gonna go eat some pumpkin bread
and plant some leaves.
You can too.
See ya out there.
(cheerful music)